Prof: Tuesday we ended
with the angry response in the
colonies to the passage of the
Stamp Act, 1765.
I talked about--I described
Patrick Henry.
We had a first--our famous
Revolution moment number one,
Patrick Henry speaking out in
the Virginia House of Burgesses,
talking about what he
dramatically called his colony's
dying liberty,
and at the very end of the
lecture I mentioned that in May
of 1765,
the Virginia House of Burgesses
passed some protesting
resolutions ultimately known as
the Virginia Resolves.
I think I said Resolutions on
Tuesday and let's stick with
Resolves, the Virginia Resolves.
And the Virginia Resolves
said--There were a number of
different --obviously--resolves
in the Virginia Resolves.
They said that the colonists
had come to Virginia with equal
rights to all British subjects;
that the colonial charter
confirmed that;
that Virginians had the right
to be governed by their own
legislature;
and that the Virginia
legislature had never forfeited
its right to impose taxes on the
colony of Virginia.
I'll repeat that again.
The Virginia Resolves,
May 1765: colonists had come to
Virginia with equal rights to
all British subjects;
colonial charters confirmed
that;
Virginians had the right to be
governed by their own colonial
legislature;
and the Virginia colonial
legislature had not forfeited
its right to impose taxes on the
colony of Virginia.
Now the House of Burgesses
passes these resolutions,
but in Virginia they weren't
even published in the local
newspaper.
However, they were published in
Rhode Island.
Okay.
I really don't make this up.
I feel like you're going to
accuse me of planting Rhode
Island randomly throughout this
course and I'm not.
It's--Really it's there all by
itself.
Rhode Island--and why Rhode
Island I can't tell you--but
indeed by happenstance,
someone in Rhode Island--It
circulates.
The resolves are circulating.
People are reading them and
they're talking about them,
but it's somebody in Rhode
Island who publishes the
Virginia Resolves in a Rhode
Island newspaper.
However, what this person does
when he publishes these resolves
is not only publish the ones
that were actually passed,
but there are two additional
resolves that get published
right alongside the ones that
were passed.
These were not passed and
possibly weren't really even
discussed, and they're more
radical than the other
resolutions.
But they're put right alongside
with no differentiation,
and these two unpassed more
radical resolutions say,
quote, "His Majesty's
liege people,
inhabitants of this colony,
are not bound to yield
obedience to any law or
ordinance whatsoever designed to
impose any taxation upon
them."
Okay.
That's a much bolder statement
than what I just said was
happening in those Virginia
Resolves.
And then the sort of more
radical unpassed resolution
number two that got published
said,
that anyone who asserted that
anyone except the Virginia
Assembly could directly tax
Virginia was,
quote, "an enemy of this,
His Majesty's colony."
Okay.
Those are two really strong
statements.
The Virginia House of Burgesses
did not pass those,
did not resolve those,
but they get published in Rhode
Island right alongside the ones
that were passed and resolved,
and so they go circulating
throughout the colonies,
making Virginia look a lot more
radical than it was at that
particular moment.
So news of this sort of new
radical version of the Virginia
Resolves gets spread throughout
the colonies and colonies are
then inspired to pass resolves
of their own.
So it's another Rhode Island
moment.
However, it is Massachusetts
that first suggests united
colonial action.
So in June of 1765,
the Massachusetts assembly
sends a circular letter to all
of the colonial assemblies--
and a circular letter is kind
of what it sounds like,
a letter intended to
circulate--to all of the
colonial assemblies inviting
them to meet in a congress in
New York in October of 1765,
quote, "to consider of a
general and united,
dutiful, loyal and humble
representation of their
condition to His Majesty and the
parliament and to implore
relief."
Okay.
So it's a united response but
it's also dutiful,
loyal and humble,
so on the one hand the fact
that there's going to be some
kind of a united colonial
statement is interesting and
forceful,
but on the other hand,
dutiful, loyal,
humble.
We're not -- we're not here
declaring independence here.
We're just kind of imploring
relief, making a statement that,
'Excuse us: we are your humble
and obedient subjects and we
don't really like this;
thank you very much.'
So it's that kind of a
statement.
Nine colonies responded.
New Hampshire declined to
participate.
Virginia, North Carolina and
Georgia couldn't participate
because their governors didn't
convene their assemblies to
elect delegates,
so there were no delegates
elected,
but all in all there were
twenty-seven men who took part
in what came to be known as the
Stamp Act Congress.
Right?
Easy enough to remember,
the Stamp Act Congress,
which met for much of October
in 1765.
Okay, the Stamp Act Congress.
The Stamp Act Congress was
actually the first of what we're
going to see is a series of
extralegal organizations created
outside of the regular colonial
political system to resist and
reform British policies --
and so it's a significant
action on the part of the
colonies.
And ultimately,
the Stamp Act Congress passed a
series of declarations,
and they kind of echo some of
the resolutions and declarations
that had been circulating and
they're going to sound not
drastically different from some
of the logic that I've been
talking about in the last
lecture or two.
And I'll just mention four of
the resolutions passed by the
Stamp Act Congress.
They declared that they owed
their allegiance to the crown
like any British subject;
they declared that they were
entitled to the rights and
liberties of any British
subject;
they said that British subjects
in the colonies could not be
taxed without their consent;
and they declared that trial by
jury was the right of every
British subject in the colonies.
So you can see their--really
their statement is saying well,
we're British subjects like any
other British subject and we're
demanding the rights and
liberties of other British
subjects.
Now it's important to note--the
resolutions are not saying that
Parliament had no right to
regulate trade in the colonies.
They're just saying that
Parliament cannot directly tax
the colonies without their
consent.
So again, it's a direct
statement, it's a strong
statement,
but it's a respectful statement
and it's not boldly sort of
altering--
at least in the minds of the
colonists--
an enormous change of policy.
They're kind of stating what
they think the state of things
is.
So clearly the Stamp Act
Congress is a step toward
colonial unity;
it's a significant step.
Now actually I want to add at
this point the answer to a
question that someone asked at
the end of class on Tuesday,
and he's lurking over there.
I think that was you -- yes.
[inaudible]
It was a really good question.
I answer questions--and then I
actually answer them in class.
It was a really good question,
and the question was did anyone
in Parliament actually oppose
the Stamp Act and if they did
what was the logic?
It's actually a really good
question and although I knew the
answer was yes,
I couldn't tell you very much
detail about that yes,
so I went and did a little
research and it's interesting.
Most members of Parliament
assumed that the Stamp Act was,
I suppose you could say
constitutional,
or that it was above-board,
proper,
that there was nothing wrong
with it as far as procedurally--
and most members of Parliament
assumed that the colonists would
agree it's constitutional--
above-board--there's nothing
wrong with it as far as the fact
that it exists;
the Stamp Act is perfectly
proper.
Some members of Parliament,
and not a lot but some,
did admit that maybe Parliament
was treading on dangerous
ground,
but even these people didn't
worry about the Stamp Act on
constitutional grounds.
They didn't say,
'Wow.
I wonder if we have the right
to do this.'
Rather, they worried that maybe
the colonists were going to be
unhappy because the Stamp Act
maybe would seem too burdensome.
Or they worried that maybe the
colonists would think this was
some kind of an aggressive
display of parliamentary power,
but members of Parliament were
actually not worried about this
seeming as though it's something
that wasn't proper,
wasn't allowable,
wasn't supposed to be done
within the confines of the
British imperial system.
So basically what you're seeing
here is sort of a version of
what I've been saying in a
variety of different ways so far
in this course.
I've been talking about
different mindsets developing,
and both sides sort of not
necessarily understanding that
there are different mindsets
evolving here.
What you're seeing here is
basically members of Parliament
just fundamentally not seeing
that the colonists had developed
a different understanding of the
workings of the British imperial
system,
and those members who were
worried about the act,
they were worried about it
being unpopular or maybe seeming
too strong but they were not
worried about any larger sort of
legal rationale.
As one member put it,--I
thought this was kind of a neat
quote--
"We are working in the
dark and the less we do the
better."
I thought that's a great quote,
because it's basically a Member
of Parliament saying,
'I'm not entirely sure.
We don't really know what we're
doing,
and we don't really know how
they're going to respond,
so we actually need to be
careful with what we're doing
because we just don't know what
the response is going to be.
They're not--They may not like
it.'
There actually was only one
Member of Parliament who was a
planter in the West Indies,
one guy who predicted,
'I think this Stamp Act is
going to produce discord and
confusion in the colonies.'
Right?
One guy, so probably afterwards
he was the guy saying,
'Yeah.
I told you.' [laughs]
'You should have listened to
me.
I told you. I knew.'
Okay.
So that's the answer to that
question.
It's a really good question
because I had just never looked
that up in any detail before.
Okay.
So--So far we've largely been
talking about speechifying,
paper-pushing,
resolves, declarations,
newspaper announcements,
but in Boston we're now about
to see some physical resistance.
Because there,
some radicals decided no more
words--action.
And these Boston radicals,
as you're about to see,
they deployed a long-held
colonial tradition of
resistance.
They basically planned a mob
action.
Now it's important to note that
mobs in early America weren't
sort of wild,
violent, out-of-control,
'oh, my gosh,
it's a riot' kind of actions.
In a way they were sort of part
of the political system,
something that people were
supposed to do when they felt
outraged.
It was sort of a way of venting
popular protest,
and usually early American mobs
were pretty conservative.
They were usually focused on
protecting the good of the
community from things like
unfairly high food prices or
illegal business practices.
Normally, they weren't really
excited about tearing things
down.
Normally, they involved some
marching and some yelling,
there was a lot of
effigy-burning,
and then people went home.
So early American mobs again
are almost kind of procedural.
They're sort of what happens
when you're upset and you're a
member of the public,
and it's not only sort of
average members of the public--
it's not only the masses taking
part in these kinds of protests.
All levels of society might
take part at one time or
another.
So in the summer of 1765,
some Bostonians decided they're
going to take advantage of this
tradition.
A group of Boston radicals who
eventually called themselves the
Sons of Liberty,
so here's yet another--Now
we're starting to get to the
part of the course where these
things come out of my mouth and
you're like 'ding,
ding, ding, ding,
Revolutionary War moments,
Sons of Liberty,' and
[inaudible]
we're going to have another one
by the end of the lecture today
but here's one:
Sons of Liberty,
Boston.
So these radicals decide
they're going to take action.
And the Sons of Liberty
basically are artisans and
shopkeepers who want to act in
resistance to the Stamp Act.
Samuel Adams--who's really more
a member of the elite,
but he nevertheless was kind of
a champion of the artisan
class--
and he's among their number too.
So let's look for a moment at
what the Sons of Liberty decide
to do and how it works out.
Okay.
So basically,
in Boston at the time there
were two really large fraternal
organizations of artisans.
There was one in the north end
of Boston, there was one in the
south end of Boston.
And the Sons of Liberty
think--well, we have these sort
of organized groups like clubs
of artisans.
Why don't we enlist the aid of
one of them?
They're sort of already
organized.
They already have a leader.
Maybe we could get them to help
us in some sort of organized
protest against the Stamp Act.
So they appeal to the south end
group, who agrees to take part
in some kind of a protest.
So now we have this radical
group, the Sons of Liberty,
who have named themselves,
so they're organized enough to
have names.
We have an organized force of
men.
And we have a focused desire to
protest against an act of
Parliament.
So this is on its way to being
a different kind of early
American mob action than these
other ones might have been.
Okay.
So in Boston the poor guy who
was the stamp agent,
the stamp distributor,
is named Andrew Oliver.
This is the person you do not
want to be at this particular
moment.
Okay.
So Andrew Oliver is the one
who's going to be giving out or
selling the stamps.
So obviously this group of men,
they want to do a mob action,
and they decide okay,
Oliver is the target.
So first they go to his
dockside warehouse.
They assume actually that
that's where the stamped paper
is going to be,
so they just destroy the
warehouse -- I mean,
like, destroy it.
Then they go to Oliver's house
and throw rocks and basically
break all of the windows.
Then they take an effigy of
Oliver and they stamp on it.
Okay. That's not my pun.
That's actually their
pun--right?
The Stamp Act--we're stamping
on Oliver--those wacky early
Americans with their wild sense
of humor.
Bad puns of early America.
That's the first of this course.
So they stamp on Andrew Oliver.
Oliver responds logically
enough by resigning as stamp
distributor, [laughs]
which I think was a wise move.
Okay. 'You think that?
Thank you very much.
I'm going home to my
broken-window house now.'
[laughs]
'No more stamps for me.'
Okay.
Not long after that,
maybe within two weeks,
that same group of men turn on
Lieutenant Governor Thomas
Hutchinson,
who seemed like a friend to the
Stamp Act.
This time the mob goes to his
house and they destroy it,
and I don't just mean rocks at
windows.
They go to Hutchinson's house,
they smash the windows,
they break in the doors,
they smash the furniture,
they cut the paintings,
they trash the clothing,
they cut down the trees in his
garden,
and they're in the process of
removing the roof [laughter]
when daylight stops them.
Okay.
So this is--On the one hand
it's sort of a weird mob.
They're like,
'excuse me.
Can you pass me that hammer?
I've got to remove this
shingle.'
They're really--
[laughs]--They're an industrious
mob action,
but they're literally
completely tearing apart
Hutchinson's pretty sort of
spiffy mansion in protest.
Attacks on stamp distributors
in other colonies followed and
there were lots of resignations
of stamp agents.
Right? 'I'm not doing the job.
[laughs]
Thanks.
I love my house.
I don't want to do this
anymore.'
So the result of all of this
kind of action is that by
November of 1765,
when the Stamp Act is actually
going to go into effect--
So first of all,
the act actually hasn't gone
into effect yet.
Everything I've talked about is
leading up to it actually going
into effect.
So November of 1765,
it's due to go into effect but
people aren't quite sure what to
do.
Do we ignore it?
Are there actually any stamp
agents left?
[laughs]
Maybe we don't have to ignore
it because nobody will sell
stamped paper.
I don't know.
And some people did just choose
to ignore the act.
Others went further and decided
to boycott British goods which,
as we're going to see further
into this course,
was sometimes a really
effective way to protest against
the mother country--
basically, hit economically and
that's bound to make an impact.
But in the middle of all this,
Grenville's ministry fell,
not because of the Stamp Act
but because of insider politics.
The colonists saw this as
providential.
Grenville's gone.
Clearly it's a sign from
providence that we are meant to
succeed here,
to come out of this looking
better than things were when we
were in the middle of it.
The new prime minister is the
Earl of Rockingham.
Now the Earl of Rockingham had
strong connections with London
merchants.
London merchants clearly are
people who are going to be
deeply affected by colonial
boycotting, so they want the
Stamp Act repealed.
So we've got this new Prime
Minister, the Earl of
Rockingham;
he's in with the merchants who
are being hurt by the boycott.
The idea now is--it would be a
fine thing if we could figure
out a way to repeal the Stamp
Act,
but the problem of course is
figuring out how to repeal it
without seeming weak,
while holding your ground.
And Rockingham eventually did
repeal the Stamp Act in March of
1766, but to save face he
assigned blame to the wounded
British economy.
He did not say anything about
colonial rights.
He said, 'Well,
the economy is suffering and so
we will repeal the Stamp Act.'
He also passed at the same time
the Declaratory Act--
the Declaratory Act--which
declared in short that
Parliament could pass laws for
the colonies,
quote, "in all cases
whatsoever."
Okay, the Declaratory Act of
1766, really strong statement.
It's like, 'yeah,
we're going to repeal the Stamp
Act but we're going to pass this
other act that says no,
we can basically pass laws for
you however we want to pass
them.
So we're not caving;
we're just sort of giving in on
this one little point.'
Now to Britain,
the Declaratory Act asserted
their control over the colonies,
their legal control over the
colonies in all cases.
To the colonists,
because it mentioned
legislation but not taxes,
it seemed to suggest that maybe
they had made their point,
that Parliament is not going to
assert taxation.
So in a way the Declaratory Act
makes things worse.
It worsens ongoing
misunderstandings between
Parliament and the colonies--
the British not fully
understanding the colonial
mindset about the workings of
the empire,
the colonists not viewing their
own logic as exceptional in any
way.
They assume that their logic
has been understood.
The Declaratory Act also didn't
really encourage compromise,
because if you think about it,
moderates on all sides were
discredited.
In England, the Declaratory Act
asserted Parliamentary power,
so it's a strong statement of
power.
In the colonies,
radicals ruled the day,
because it seemed as though
they'd made their point.
So as far as the colonies were
concerned, the Stamp Act crisis
moved many to accept radical
leadership;
it appears to be working.
It also revealed to the
colonies the power of uniting
the colonies to bring pressure
against England,
which also seemed to have
worked.
Now once again in the middle of
all this, the Prime Minister yet
again is replaced.
Clearly, this is not the time
to be a Prime Minister in
England.
It's kind of a rocky time going
on.
So--Rocky time was not meant to
be a pun.
The Earl of Rockingham goes
down in this rocky time and
Charles--I heard a groan.
I didn't do it on purpose.
It just sort of happened.
I'm sorry.
It's a bad pun that I take full
responsibility for.
But the Earl of Rockingham--His
ministry falls.
Charles Townshend takes his
place.
Charles Townshend,
the new Prime Minister--and
he's given the task of balancing
the budget in 1767.
And like Grenville before him,
Townshend first looks to
England itself and issues new
taxes in England,
but again he still needs more
income and he does next turn to
the colonies,
and he devises a scheme that he
thinks isn't going to be too
upsetting to these sort of
touchy colonials.
He says he's going to proceed,
quote, "with great
delicacy,"
right?
Because it's clear now,
'they get upset over there;
they get upset.
We need to be careful,
I'm going to proceed with great
delicacy.'
He understands their
sensitivity about this whole
issue of taxation.
So he decides he's going to ask
for customs duties on items that
the colonies import from
Britain, like glass,
silk, paper,
paint and--tea.
[laughs]
You can see where we're going.
But this is not an internal tax.
This is an external tax.
It's not a tax on things within
the colonies.
It's not a tax on legal
documents.
It's not a tax on playing cards
like the Stamp Act.
It's an external tax.
It's customs duties.
And like before,
Townshend wants the money
raised by this to go to pay for
royal administration in the
colonies,
so also the money raised isn't
going back to England;
it's going to be spent on the
colonies.
Townshend also reorganized the
customs service in the colonies,
basically tossing out old
customs agents who had been
bought by colonial merchants and
putting hand-picked men in their
place.
So all in all,
Townshend thought--surely these
are tame enough measures that
the colonists aren't going to
object to them.
Right?
This seems as though they're
accommodating,
they're mild,
nothing very dramatic is being
done here.
These come to be known as the
Townshend Acts of 1767.
And sure enough,
the initial response to the
Townshend Acts is relatively
weak.
But, colonial anger is raised
yet again by a publication by a
colonist named John Dickinson.
He's a Pennsylvanian.
He's in Pennsylvania and he
writes a series of letters.
First they appear in a
Pennsylvania newspaper.
They're eventually published in
other colonial newspapers,
and then finally they're put
together and published in a
pamphlet.
This is all in 1767--and the
pamphlet is named Letters
from a Farmer in Pennsylvania to
the Inhabitants of the British
Colonies. They had very
literal titles in these days;
this is one of them.
John Dickinson,
Pennsylvanian,
Letters from a Farmer in
Pennsylvania to the Inhabitants
of the British Colonies.
Now Dickinson actually--When
you read these,
he's pretty moderate in tone.
And most of what he does is he
uses past precedent to argue
against the right of Parliament
to directly tax the colonies.
He asserts directly:
we're not talking about
independence;
we're just talking about past
precedent.
However, he also says,
and this is a quote from him,
"We cannot be happy
without being free.
We cannot be free without being
secure in our property.
We cannot be secure in our
property,
if without our consent,
others may,
as by right,
take it away,
that taxes imposed on us by
Parliament,
do thus take it away."
That's really clear,
direct logic.
Right?
We can't be happy without being
free.
We can't be free without being
secure in our property.
We can't be secure in our
property if without our consent,
others may take it away,
and Parliament seems to be
taking it away.
So Dickinson isn't arguing
anything amazingly new here,
but he's certainly stating it
with real clarity and real
power.
And he also appears to be
saying, 'Well,
some of that stuff we learned
from that whole Stamp Act thing?
I think they apply as well to
this new Townshend Act thing.'
He appears to be drawing a
pattern.
So Letters from a Farmer in
Pennsylvania ultimately has
an impact.
It's a strong statement.
Up in Boston,
there was also some writing
going on.
And there, Samuel Adams,
who was in the Massachusetts
assembly, wrote a circular
letter that he sent to other
colonies.
Yet again, another circular
letter,
and this time it's a circular
letter protesting against the
Townshend Acts and it's
moderate,
but it's criticizing the acts.
It does deny--It's--We're --
'This isn't about independence,
we're not trying to rebel
here'--but it does urge joint
colonial resistance to the
Townshend Acts.
Now back in England,
many people urged a lenient
response to this.
If you think about it,
potentially,
it's a scary thing.
You have this guy--this radical
guy in Boston--who's urging
joint colonial resistance to an
act of Parliament.
So as you will see,
some people get rather upset by
this, but not everybody.
Some people say, 'Well, okay.
Let's not over-respond;
let's not overreact.'
However, the British Secretary
of State, Lord Hillsborough,
really saw this as organized
resistance and refused to stand
for it.
So in 1768, privately
consulting with the King,
so kind of doing this off on
the side,
he instructed the Governor of
Massachusetts to dissolve the
Massachusetts assembly unless
they took back the letter.
He also sent a letter to all
royal governors telling them to
ignore the Massachusetts letter
or else he would dissolve their
legislatures too.
Okay.
That's--There's a strong
statement for you that's clearly
bound to make colonists get
very, very upset.
Hillsborough also,
knowing that people are going
to get upset,
urged General Thomas
Gage--who's commander-in-chief
of the army and at the time was
posted in New York--
he urges Gage in New York to
prepare his troops in case
they're needed in Boston.
Okay.
So he's anticipating there
might be a response;
it would be nice to have troops
potentially ready to go to
Boston.
So now, troops are being
organized,
there's threats about
dissolving assemblies,
and communication between the
colonies in the form of a
circular letter is being
discouraged.
So clearly, if you're a
colonist at this point,
there appears to be a plan of
repression, right?
A plan.
There seems to be a system of
tyranny.
There seems to be some kind of
organized attack on colonial
liberties,
and I'm emphasizing plan and
system and organized because
next week that's the direction
we're going to be going with the
lectures.
We're going to be looking at
what I call the logic of
resistance, or--how does all of
this add up in the minds of the
colonists?
What's--what are they
drawing--what conclusions are
they drawing based on actions
that are happening?
And as we'll see in the
lectures and in the readings for
next week,
there's a lot of conclusions
being drawn about an actual
system of tyranny,
which is a very
eighteenth-century way of kind
of looking at it.
So colonists are wondering if
there's a sort of system of
repression being put in place.
Meanwhile, Parliament,
eventually, in 1770,
repeals most of the Townshend
Acts but does preserve the tax
on tea,
partly for revenue and partly
to prove that they still have
the right to tax the colonies.
So we're half-seeing revenue
raising and half-seeing an
argument here.
And probably there was an
assumption on the part of
Parliament that by repealing
most of the acts things would
quiet down,
but as events in Boston were
about to prove this would not be
the case.
As we're about to see,
between 1768 and 1774,
Boston really ends up taking
center stage.
And thanks in part to the
actions of Samuel Adams who
really is--
you'll see today--a brilliant
propagandist and a man with a
really fierce sense of his
rights--
his British rights and his
grievances as an English
subject.
And I will add that Samuel
Adams did brew beer.
Right?
He actually is--Samuel Adams is
associated with beer,
so truth in advertising,
though I have no idea if that's
an accurate portrait of Sam
Adams.
Student: It's Paul
Revere.
Sam Adams is too ugly.
Prof: Sam Adams is too
ugly.
[laughs] Oh, poor Sam Adams.
I feel very bad now.
[laughs]
Oh.
Well, he's not attractive but I
don't know if he's ugly.
I feel bad.
Now I'm going to have to find a
way to redeem Sam Adams in the--
[laughs].
Thank you very much.
No wonder I didn't think it was
entirely an accurate
portrait--Okay.
And yet he is associated with
beer.
Okay.
So Sam Adams--He's going to
have a moment.
October of 1768,
troops actually arrive in
Boston at the instigation of
Massachusetts Royal Governor
Francis Bernard,
who's alarmed at the sort of
radical rumblings that he's
hearing.
Parliament makes things worse
by--in December of 1768--
by proposing that the
ringleaders behind that circular
letter that seems like organized
resistance,
that they should be brought to
trial for treason,
and using an obscure law,
they say that they should be
brought to trial for treason in
England;
they should go trial in
England.
Okay.
Again not something that's
going to make colonists really
happy.
Not surprisingly,
when you have the next election
for the assembly in
Massachusetts in 1769,
a large number of radicals get
voted in.
And this new assembly passes,
logically enough,
radical resolutions again
largely the work of Samuel
Adams,
the sadly not good-looking
Samuel Adams,
[laughter]
who declared in these
resolutions that "no man
can be justly taxed by,
or bound in conscience to obey,
any law to which he has not
given his consent in person or
by his representative."
Okay.
That's a stronger statement
than the ones we've had before.
What he's saying
here--Formally,
like other colonial assemblies,
the Massachusetts assembly was
saying,
'well, Parliament can legislate
for us but they can't directly
tax us without our consent,' but
this statement says,
'Parliament can't legislate for
us if we have no say in the
process.'
Bang.
That's a very strong statement.
So clearly there's a lot of
emotion that has been raised
about what the British
administration is doing.
It's being vented in radical
resolves like that.
The arrival of troops in Boston
in 1768 ended up really focusing
these feelings of grievance,
these--this anger,
these sort of passions.
You have troops being sent to
Boston at a moment where people
are angry at the British;
surely enough you can see that
the colonists are going to vent
their feelings towards the
soldiers.
Troops being sent to Boston
increase colonial assumptions
that they are being treated as
second-class citizens,
as lower-class subjects,
as people who are not equal to
other British subjects within
the empire.
And Samuel Adams said this
really clearly in a newspaper
article written at the time.
He wrote: "It is well
known from the first landing of
the troops that the troops'
behavior was to a great degree
insolent and such as looked as
if they really believed that we
were a country of rebels and
that they were sent here to
subdue us."
Right?
Again Adams is propagandizing
so he's always saying things
with a sort of extra twist,
but what he's saying is,
it was very clear that when the
troops arrived they were
treating us like lowly rebels
and that they were sent here to
subdue us.
Okay.
So given all of these
feelings--fears about a
tyrannical standing army that's
inside a sort of system of
tyranny--
it makes sense that when these
troops arrive in Boston
relations are not going to be
good between people in Boston
and soldiers in Boston,
which brings us to yet another
sort of bell-ringing
Revolutionary War moment,
a particularly noteworthy
active resistance in Boston
later memorialized by clever
colonial propagandists as the
Boston Massacre.
Right?
That's how we know it today.
They gave it--Colonists gave it
that name.
It's a snappy name. Right?
We kept the name.
We like the name.
It really has some zing,
makes a political point.
So let's look for a minute here
at the details of the Boston
Massacre,
partly because they're really
interesting as you'll see--
it's just a really interesting
incident--
but also because I think if you
look at how the colonists and
the soldiers were interacting,
it really will reveal something
about the dynamic of
colonial-British relations at
the time.
Now first off,
it's important to understand
that the Boston Massacre wasn't
this little isolated moment of
conflict between soldiers and
citizens.
Between 1768 and early 1770,
tensions were building between
the colonists and the troops,
and in early 1770 there
actually were a number--
several--different outbursts of
hostility between townspeople
and soldiers in Boston.
So an example: On March 2^(nd),
Samuel Grey,
a rope maker,
asked a passing soldier if he
wanted a job,
and when the soldier,
who was probably underpaid,
said, 'Yeah,
actually I could use a second
job,' Grey laughed and said,
'Good. Go clean my outhouse.'
This did not make the soldier
happy,
so the soldier slugged Grey,
and Grey hit back,
and other people--soldiers ran
out and other colonists ran over
and there was a fight--
there was a street fight.
A few days later, March 5^(th),
another fight broke out when
another civilian said something
insulting to another soldier and
they began punching each other
and there was another street
fight--
and that would be the first in
a series of increasingly
agitated clashes on that day,
March 5^(th),
1770, that's going to end in
gunfire.
But obviously the Boston
Massacre is not the first moment
of conflict.
Now later that evening--There's
a series of little outbursts
that day, March 5^(th).
Later that evening a small boy
walking out on the street began
taunting a soldier,
and the soldier responded by
knocking him down.
Well, the boy got up,
went off, found some other
colonists in the street and
complained that a soldier over
there had knocked him down.
Okay.
So in this environment that's
going to really get a lot of
colonists upset.
So a little ring of people
surrounds the kid.
'He's knocking down a kid?
We need to go get the soldiers.'
Right?
So a small group of colonists
heads off to the barracks to
actually accost the soldiers,
but they're held off by guards.
Soon thereafter,
someone begins ringing the bell
of the Boston Meeting House--
and normally when you ring the
bell of the Boston Meeting House
that's a signal for fire,
and fire is a serious thing in
a place full of wooden
buildings.
Right?
So if the bell is ringing that
means, 'oh, my God,
there's a fire'--and everyone
does what they should do when
there's an alarm of fire.
Right?
The bell goes off and dozens
and dozens and dozens of people
run in to the street thinking
that there's a fire.
Now from this point we have
several accounts.
There are a number of accounts
about what happened,
some of them conflict,
and we're going to be looking
at two accounts today.
We're going to be looking at
one by British general Thomas
Gage, I mentioned before,
the commander-in-chief of the
British army in America.
He's posted in New York but he
had gotten a very detailed
report about what happened in
Boston from his soldiers--
his officers and men--on
exactly what they think they
experienced.
And then the other account is
by Samuel Adams,
radical propagandist--clearly
is going to be a very different
point of view.
Okay.
So Gage sends a very detailed
report to a member of the King's
cabinet in London based on what
the British soldiers in Boston
told him.
Assuming that the colonists in
general were insolent and were
pushing to get more than they
deserved,
Gage says in his statement,
he suspects that the entire
thing was deliberate.
He thinks that there were some
colonists who probably
prearranged what happened,
armed themselves with sticks,
rocks, bricks and snowballs.
I'm sorry, but snowballs just
never sounds like a scary weapon
to me,
even though bad things happen
here,
and I know I would not like to
be hit with a snowball,
but it's not like a brick.
But snowballs are--Everyone's
complaining about snowballs in
these accounts you'll see.
Somehow it just makes it seem
less serious.
I don't know why.
But anyway, he thinks it's
deliberate;
he thinks the colonists
prearranged it;
that they armed themselves with
sticks, rocks,
bricks and snowballs;
planned the ringing of the bell
so that Bostonians would rise up
at the signal and attack the
soldiers.
Okay.
So this is what Gage
assumes--and here is Gage's
account.
"Many people came out of
their houses supposing a fire in
the town,
and several officers on the
same supposition were repairing
to their posts;
but meeting with mobs were
reviled, attacked,
and those who could not escape
knocked down and treated with
great inhumanity."
Right?
'Those crude,
nasty colonists are treating
the soldiers very badly.'
"Different mobs paraded
through the streets,
passing the several barracks
and provoking the soldiers to
come out.
One body went to the main guard
where every provocation was
given, without effect,
for the guard remained quiet.
From thence the mob proceeded
to a sentinel"--
a single sentinel --
"posted upon the
customhouse,
at a small distance from the
guard,
and attacked him.
He defended himself as well as
he could, calling out for
help."
Okay.
There's one guy according to
this account,
and the mob attacks the one guy
standing in front of the customs
house.
"And people ran to the
guard to give information of his
danger."
So according to Gage,
people see this one guy getting
attacked by a bunch of people
and they--
actually colonists--run to get
other soldiers to help the one
guy.
So according to Gage's account,
they're not all crazy radicals
in Boston.
Some of them are out there
helping us.
"Captain Preston,
hearing the sentinel was in
danger of being
murdered"--already;
we got to murder really
fast--"he detached a
sergeant and 12 men to relieve
him and soon after followed
himself to prevent to prevent
any rash act on the part of the
troops.
This party as well as the
sentinel was immediately
attacked,
some colonists throwing bricks,
stones,
pieces of ice,
and snowballs"--
once again the
snowballs--"at them whilst
others advanced up to their
bayonets and endeavored to close
with them to use their bludgeons
and clubs,
calling out to them to fire if
they dared and provoking them in
a most opprobrious
language."
Right?
Again -- 'rude colonists
behaving badly.'
So we have a group of soldiers
that are lined up in front of
the customs house running to
protect a fellow soldier
supposedly being murdered at the
hands of a crude and angry mob
armed with sticks and rocks and
snowballs.
Okay. Let's segue over to Adams.
Adams writes a series of
newspaper essays for the
Boston Gazette describing
the same incident,
often quoting testimony from
the trial of the soldiers that
obviously takes place after this
incident,
but also obviously quoting them
and telling the story with his
own radical flair.
Now remember here the different
reasons for these accounts.
And this is actually a great
example of the importance of
thinking about the nature of
historical evidence.
Who things are written to and
why they're written has a
lot to do with how you
interpret them.
Right?
You have these two documents
being written for really
specific reasons to a very
specific audience.
So Gage is trying to explain to
royal authorities a shooting
that never should have happened.
He has to somehow justify this,
so he's appealing to the people
he sent the letter to--
whoever this royal authority
was--and he has to assume that
other royal authorities are
going to see it.
He's appealing to them as
fellow sophisticated Englishmen
who understand the nature of
things out in this sort of
frontier colony area,
crude colonists,
upset colonists.
So in a sense Gage is offering
sort of an extreme version of
some typical English sentiment
among--about the colonies.
Adams is writing to the
colonial public and he's trying
to raise a public outcry against
the soldiers and obviously by
association,
against the British
administration,
and clearly Adams is going to
want to depict these soldiers as
cruel and tyrannical as all
standing armies are,
so in a sense Adams is
certainly going to be offering
an extreme version of some
colonial sentiment at the time
about the soldiers and maybe
about the British administration
generally.
Okay.
So here is Adams' version from
the moment when the bell starts
to ring.
"The ringing of the bells
alarmed the town,
it being supposed by the people
in general there was a fire.
As the people came in to the
street, the boy who had been
knocked down told them that the
sentry had knocked him
down."
Okay, and I'm actually quoting
so this--you can't blame me for
this.
The boy says,
'A sentry knocked me down,'
points at the solider and says,
"There's the son of a
b[it]ch that knocked me
down."
[laughter]
I love that that detail is in
the newspaper [laughs]--and
that's another one of those
things that like--they said that
in 1770?
[laughter] And they did.
Other people heard this and
cried, "Kill him."
[laughter] Hey.
[laughs]
"The sentry ran to the
custom-house steps,
knocked at the door,
but could not get in."
'Excuse me.
[laughs]
They're going to kill me.'
He primed and loaded his gun
and leveled it and told the
people to stand off,
and called to the main guard.
"Various were the
dispositions and inclinations of
the people"
at this point.
"The cooler sort advised
to go home: The curious were
willing to stay and see the
event,
and those whose feelings were
warmer,
perhaps partook of the boy's
resentment."
And here he's trying to justify
like--okay there were some
crazy, radical guys but they
were probably upset with the
boy.
Right? They weren't angry.
They were just--Of course
they'd be upset.
The boy was attacked.
The soldiers moved to help the
sentry standing alone before the
mob.
Adams said the soldiers moved,
quote,
with "an haughty air--
they push'd their bayonets and
damn'd the people as they went
along--
and when they arriv'd at their
post,
one witness who is a young
gentleman of a liberal education
and an unspotted character,
[laughter]
declared, that one of the
soldiers whom he particularly
named,
loaded his gun,
pushed him with his bayonet and
damn'd him."
Ooh. Okay.
[laughter]
So here, according to Adams,
there's this rude,
imperious British soldier
treating the young gentleman of
a liberal education and
unspotted character [laughs]
like a lesser being.
Okay.
So now both narrators have
gotten us to the same point.
We have soldiers lined up.
They have just very visibly
loaded their guns.
In front of them stands British
Captain Preston with--who is in
command of the men--and in front
of Preston is an angry crowd.
So according to Gage,
at this point Preston--
soldiers behind him--crowd in
front of him--
he's trying to calm the
situation down,
and supposedly he's asked,
'Are you going to ask those
soldiers to fire on us?'
and Preston says, 'Yeah.
See, the guns are behind me and
you're in front of me.
No. Really.
[laughter]
It wouldn't be a good idea for
them to fire now because I'll
die.'
Right?
[laughter]
He's like 'No.'
It's a good point I think.
But "all he could say had
no effect, and one of the
soldiers, receiving a violent
blow, instantly fired.
Captain Preston turned around
to see who fired,
and received a blow upon his
arm, which was aimed at his
head;
and the mob,
at first seeing no execution
done and imagining the soldiers
had only fired powder to
frighten them,
grew more bold and attacked
with greater violence,
continually striking at the
soldiers and pelting them,
and calling out to them to
fire."
And we have Captain Preston's
description of what he heard
from the crowd.
He says the crowd was yelling,
"Come on,
you rascals,
bloody backs,
lobster scoundrels."
[laughs]
Quite a little string of
insults.
"Fire if you dare.
You dare not fire."
Okay.
So Gage goes on,
"The soldiers at length
perceiving their lives in
danger,
and hearing the word 'fire' all
round them,
three or four of them fired one
after another,
and again three more in the
hurry and confusion.
Four or five persons were
unfortunately killed"--un
fortunately--"and more
wounded."
Okay.
So that's basically the end of
Gage's account.
Clearly, in his account the
soldiers are under serious
attack.
Adams tells a different story.
Adams says, 'Yes,
the crowd was yelling at the
troops but they had insulted the
crowd and loaded their guns.
Yes, they had sticks but
everybody was carrying sticks
these days because everyone was
scared of the soldiers,
so everyone naturally walked
around in the streets with
sticks.'
Now maybe that's true,
which tells you a lot about the
streets of Boston,
or maybe it's not in which case
it's really creative.
[laughter]
'Yes, the crowd hit at the
soldiers' guns but they were
trying to push them away.'
So Adams says it's not an
uncontrolled mob;
it's actually a group of people
carrying their normal,
everyday sticks,
[laughter]
pushing in to hear Captain
Preston answer the question
about whether or not he was
going to order the troops to
fire.
At this moment,
Adams says, one of the soldiers
was hit by a stick,
staggered, fired his gun at the
crowd upon which several
soldiers fired and says Adams,
'they reloaded their guns.
They were going to fire again.'
Some of the crowd moved away.
One man went up to a soldier
and asked him to his face if he
was going to fire,
and supposedly the soldier
said, quote,
"Yes by the eternal
God" at which point the
colonists knocked him down.
[laughter]
I love all the detail.
At this point Preston called
out to his men not to fire and
they stopped,
and here Adams says,
"I am no Soldier,
and never desired to be one:
but I appeal to those who are,
whether the words,
'Don't fire,' are words of
command in the British army;
and whether there is not some
other word which Soldiers are
taught to understand,
more proper to be given on such
an occasion ...
which would have prevented such
rashness."
So here he's saying,
'The guy didn't even call out
cease fire.
He said, 'Don't. Stop.''
[laughs] Great.
Thank you, Captain Preston.
And then Adams describes the
people who died.
He makes special note of the
fact that Grey,
the rope maker who insulted the
sentry by asking him to clean
the outhouse,
is killed in the clash.
Coincidence or murder?
[laughter] Adams is good.
Right?
And so here Adams is tossing
out the suggestion that maybe
the troops were just looking for
an excuse to fire on the
townspeople--
and then really get that nasty
Grey--
plotting maybe.
And the British too,
as you've heard,
are wondering if maybe this is
a plot on the part of the
colonists.
Maybe they're actually just
trying to rob the customs house
and this whole thing was an
elaborate ploy by the colonists
just to rob the customs house
behind the guard.
So you can really see from
these two accounts,
and from the details contained
within them,
the animosity and the sense of
alienation between the colonists
and the soldiers on both sides,
and you can also see really
dramatically the fears on both
sides that there's some kind of
a plot;
there's some kind of a plot of
resistance or tyranny,
depending on which side you're
on.
Somehow this is organized and
it's not good and it has to be
stopped--and both sides have
come to that same point.
And I will stop there and we
will continue next week on to
the logic of resistance.